welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka mr. marvel and
this is the channel where we explain it
so you don't have to avengers endgame is
the perfect way to end the last 11 years
of the MCU its finale brings together
the entire ensemble of Marvel characters
in an epic showdown against the mad
Titan Thanos though the film feels
pretty fitting and its final few moments
there actually was an original ending
that saw a slightly different send-off
for one of our heroes and throughout
this video I'll be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the first cut of the movie this is full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't seen
Avengers and game yet then I highly
recommend that you turn off the video
now as we will be discussing one of the
big moments in its last half hour but
everyone else who's still here thank you
for clicking this video I hope you enjoy
it now sit back relax and let's get into
my original ending explain breakdown for
Avengers endgame
okay so end game concludes with Tony
Stark taking the Infinity stones from
Thanos and using them to carry out the
snap
though this defeats all of the villains
forces and dusts the antagonist as well
carrying out the snap causes Tony to
critically damaged himself whilst in the
final cut it is a flash of bright light
and Tony is told that everyone will be
okay before passing away originally the
Russo brothers who directed the film had
the character transported to the
soulstone dimension similar to the scene
from infinity war where Thanos is
reunited with a young Gamora in the
scene Tony
arrived there to find a teenage version
of his daughter who was played by none
other than 13 reasons why star Catherine
Lankford Lankford's casting was quite
heavily reported on throughout last year
but many were dismayed to see that she
wasn't in the finished product so we
know for definite now that this is where
she came into the
and switch on Gomorrah she told Tony
that his sacrifice was worth it and that
they were all going to be okay because
of him the Russo said that was this
scene did work on paper upon previewing
it with test audiences they bound it
confusing and didn't understand who this
person was basically imagine the Iron
Man 3 kid saga all over again times 1000
and you get the gist of it I can't see
why it was cut as dialogue wise it's
pretty similar to what Pepper says and
they sort of covering the same ground in
what was already a pretty packed film in
addition to this we do see young Morgan
at the funeral after so it does sort of
bring more confusion into the film
personally though I would have liked to
have seen it as I think it's a pretty
cool callback to infinity war and it
showcases that tony was happy with his
decision whereas you get the feeling
that Thanos wasn't still the send-off
that we got was good enough but it's
nice to know that even beyond these
movies Morgan will be okay which is of
course what Tony wanted most of all and
of course loved hear your thoughts on
this alternate ending and if you would
have liked to have seen it comment below
and let me know and if you love this
video 3000 then please like it and make
sure you check out my top 5 pan theories
for Spider Man far from home which would
be linked at the end we've also just
launched a merch section so if you want
to support the channel and get some cool
clothing out of it make sure you click
the boxes in the description below this
is a channel for people who are super
into superheroes so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]